on a la chance aussi d'avoir une main
une magnifique des quotas comme giuly
mais on a aussi je vous dis une poule en
chocolat que j'ai décidé d'offrir au
public à 12,7 poule en chocolat
elle est magnifique parce que je vous le
dis il y avait eu ou la poule à ce qu'on
peut amener la poule en chocolat
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
chocolat pour leur dire qu'ils m'ont
fait une fiche ça allait mais lionel en
masse que vous rendez compte chez vous
est-ce que vous rendez compte si vous
regardez mes mais en 2011 réelles et
bouffer aux populations calmez vous
calmez vous voyez pas que je suis jeune
je venais me avec une émission
catastrophique on vient pour faits non
mais on a quand même mis une fille pour
cette poule à qui en plus beauf et alors
je vais savoir de tout de suite qui a
mangé eu le culot
il est 19h10 lui c'est parti on me dit
que cette poule au chocolat a été mise
sur le plateau à 18h55 à un récent les
naim n'était plus sur le plateau on dit
même 58 médailles vous aviez quitté le
plateau
vous étiez en train de manger du pain
azyme donc ce n'est pas vous mais étant
donné que je me doutais qu'il y avait
des petits malins j'ai truffé
le plateau de caméras de surveillance à
son origine mais des vrais km est vrai
qu'un jour j'étais tranquillement chez
moi hier à 16 heures tranquillement les
doigts de pied en éventail
un train de regarder la finale de monte
carlo
ah oui enfin magnifique score sur ces
huit pouvez demander à ses huit
d'arrêter d'acheter le tennis ça
m'arrangerait albert salinis que ça nous
a flingué le week end un accord c'est
fabio fognini l'a fait d'ailleurs un
score de merde on a fait 120 mille
téléspectateurs aiment pas prêt mais
c'était bien que oui bah oui mais
c'était bien mais bon on aurait préféré
comme en plus de montrer les filles
merci non la veille avec nadal s'était
pas beaucoup mieux donc s'ils pouvaient
rester chez eux mais tout finit ça on
arrête avec ça mais c'est bon mais je
m'en fous j'étais tranquillement en
train de regarder cette finale et là
j'ai eu cet éclair de génie
et non pas de gagner non je n'aurais pas
eu cette idée je me suis dit je sens
qu'avec la pac qui arrive il va y avoir
des abus il va la voir
grâce à des échauffourées des larcins
donc j'ai mis sept caméras de
surveillance qui a mangé la poule coup
is it in the pool exact après on a les
images et vous le dis je ne connais pas
le coupable on n'a pas voulu me le dire
badinter en revanche en revanche je vais
le découvrir en même temps que vous et
le coupable bull je vous le dis par ce
qui se passe hors affaire à moi à la
personne il y aura forcément des
sanctions est ce que j'appelle des fc
c'est quoi des f series est d'ailleurs
ds et 3ds
les fonctions culinaire regardes tu dois
t'attendre fans et moi calibre ça n'est
pas clair pour l'instant ça n'est pas
calé pour l'instant ça n'est pas calé
pour l'instant ch
pour l'instant ça n'est pas qu'ils
voient là non pour moi ce n'est pas
qu'elle est pour l'instant au
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je vous ai défendu jusqu'à la fin je
vais demander stopper josette tu peux
venir tu m'enlèves tous les mois la stib
et ce coup là tu m'énerves si l'arrivée
non non non non non non non non non tu
es privés de deco tu es tu donne je
donne dans la partie donne cela pas mais
bien aussi donner ce lapin vous avez été
dure à necker alors par contre deux mois
ça parce qu'on en a besoin
jamais non merci en tout cas bravo quai
ligny c'est dingue parce que je sais que
j'arrive en avance mais ça y est la plus
facile à mener 1